estamos comiendo serum Oh Sally big one
we're de aqui pero NOS falta
iguala a town that's become a symbol of
forced disappearances in Mexico in 2014
43 students from the ayotzinapa school
disappeared here at the hands of police
the search for them uncovered mass
graves but the remains that were found
didn't belong to the students parent o
se SI no sanas normally stays quienes
own es es como su hasty group turns out
I yahtzee napa was just the tip of the
iceberg for an epidemic of
disappearances in Mexico these families
represent the thousands of others who
vanished without a trace every week
patio Scott opens the doors of the San
Gerardo church to those searching for
their missing loved ones la gente
necesito encontrar pass necesita apoyo
cada martez nohrin emos y este pues
estamos un rato de accion intercom bien
algunas experiencias acquaintances
experiencias de sus familiares
desaparecidos cuando yo SE para serum l
mayor tenia venti Quattro en y el mejor
el mejor SI ama Omar Omar cannon Avila
el menor SI ama era mi avete cannon a
ver que mattamas la duda de server
system muerto subimos Kayla chose saber
que esten Finas
yo sueno EO que lo paso que estoy con el
tengo su ropa la veo la partie OU tengo
su zapatos tengo fotos y la verna
yetunde impotencia aqui cidade quisiera
Venice's personas que lesion SI danyo
vivimos Cognito no platicamos lo que NOS
hace do mario was one of the founding
members of the committee of the other
disappeared of iguala he and his sister
Maya have been looking for their older
brother Tomas since 2012 he says that
the ayotzinapa mobilizations brought
other families out of the woodwork who
had stories of their own missing
llegando alla NOS dimos cuenta que vea
muchisimas familias y que también 10 en
el mismo proposito de salir de buscar
pero no lo cien por que estaban solas
los como que agora most wasted a salir a
buscar campo yeah no estaba mo solos
llegamos mess familias que busca vamos a
nuestros familiar
so it's three o'clock and the family
members who have disappeared loved ones
just left that's four hours of meetings
and retelling of the story of how their
brother or their husband or their
daughter was disappeared how they went
out to work and how they never came back
I talked to a grandmother who basically
just broke down crying in front of me
you know she didn't want to be filmed
she's afraid a grandmother is afraid for
her life mucha gente tiene miedo darla
car si por que sigue in seguro de diente
asegura que no 2 volver a pasa es otro
saawan la cara por que tal vez alguien
pueda be a vs alguien sep algo de Tomas
police okay the risk of repercussion is
high in August a member of the group
miguel angel jimenez Blanco was found
dead in his car he was one of the first
people to search for both the students
and the other disappeared el fue una
persona que no sense in yo a dominar el
miedo a salir de buscar a nuestros
familiaris era una persona que no tenia
familiarise desaparecidos pero una chava
para que no sufrir a lo mismo y subo
todos los dias opposes vo que la gente
que in chiarrin SI llego algo de metal
los puede identificar merapi de SI mi el
dia de mañana megan enter our este vez
mi nombre este pedazo de fierro me vaya
identificar que soy yo their sacrifice
is minimal compared to their pain but
what these families are up against is
massive a relentless drug economy and a
war that has turned their communities
into collateral damage a year ago on the
night of September 26th
students from the ayotzinapa rural
school came here to the town of iguala